الآن هذا المساء أعلنها نعمان بك
وقال أيضا إن لديه مثل هذا الطلب.
والشيء من Kılıçdaroğlu أي 3
الوزارة
عرضت بالطبع
نعمان بك خاصة في هذا الصدد.
أي وزارة مثل AFAD أو حتى
وهي وزارة الداخلية.
الوزارة التي تتبعها شركة afad
لذلك إذا تم إعطاء هذا
في العمل في مكافحة الإرهاب
مقبولة إذا تم اتخاذ الخطوات اللازمة.
كما أستطيع ، نعمان بك نعمان بك أيضًا
هذا في برنامج الليلة التلفزيوني
أعلن مثل هذا الاقتراح
بالطبع ، نورمال سأل عن نفسه
بمعنى آخر ، رئيسنا لا يستجيب لمثل هذه المطالب.
مغلق
لقد قال بالفعل أن هناك معركة ضد الإرهاب.
وزارة شؤون الوقت حتى تفعل ذلك
ربما طلبت هذا منك الآن Hope
Ozdag هذا جيد
مفتوح لأن Özdağ من Kılıçdaroğlu
كل ما تريد وزارة الداخلية
لا اعرف ما قلته
لا أعلم ، بالطبع ، إنها معلومات واردة.
لقد قلتها من قبل
بالتأكيد سياسة مساومة.
نحن لا نقوم بالسياسة المبنية على الأخلاق والمبادئ
قلنا أننا سنفعلها ، وفي هذا النوع من الزنزانات ، نعمان
أعني ، هذه هي الطريقة التي يستخدمها السيد.
ماذا يريد
في وزارة الخارجية ، مثل أ
طلب ونعمان بك فعل ذلك.
عندما يقول رئيسنا إنه لن يقبل
أكثر كسرا